okay here we go
[Music]
i'm sorry okay how are we going to go
all right look uh before we start the
show i just wanted you to know something
uh sometimes people think that what we
discuss here what i'm about to say is
hyperbolic it's not at all i stand by it
100
and i would like to see other so-called
conservatives and republicans do it
we'll get into what's happening in
minneapolis with teachers we'll get into
what's happening nationally with the
teachers unions what's happening in
florida we absolutely need to defund the
federal department of education
not saying that as a click bait
not saying that to reel you in
it is absolutely not only what i believe
but what i'm pretty sure
you will at least understand when you
watch this show we don't need it
republicans know we don't need it those
in the federal government we know we
don't need it and teachers unions
certainly know that we don't need it
that's the bulk of today's show let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
changes
[Music]
there you go i was a little late on
taking a sip really because i did the
cold open by the way you guys can you
know let's hit this right now comment
below if you want us to do more of these
cold weapons because we do a lot of
these intros and sometimes we have
people saying i don't like the angels
and want more intros you know what we
can't please everybody they can't all be
diamonds
like liz cheney
you know some people take the pressure
and they they're turned into a diamond
and some people take pre and they're
still just left with coal it's like you
start with clay and you're setting out
to make a beautiful vaz some people say
base i say boss and then sometimes you
know you pet you you demean more ghost
this whole thing
and you just end up with a pot
that's liz cheney 37 points and she lost
so we'll be talking about that we'll be
talking about the teachers unions first
off the racist stuff that's going on in
one particular state then the solutions
from one particular state florida and
then the solution nationally why public
schools suck in general and why we need
to defund the department of education
and why people are concerned that donald
trump has alluded to the fact that he
would at least start the process so you
can let me know what you think before
you watch this show
you think you really need the department
of education i'll show you why we don't
and uh gerald how are you i am doing
very well and i'm glad we're talking
about this yeah three a curveball there
i said and then i went to you i was
ready yeah okay i was happy for it yeah
i was how are you i'm fine yeah i just
hate schools how's the boot
i don't have the boot on right now
they said i can take it off every now
and then i find the boot makes my foot
hurt more it's like a stretch fracture
it does it's kind of like braces a
little bird bones in your feet all right
and then uh you know him you love him
quickest man on his feet we are on tour
go to light earthquaker.com
tour because there are other dates some
of them are sold out a lot of them
aren't because we've expanded the
theaters phoenix september 16th ahoy
houston september 17th um dave landau
how are you ahoy i'm good good
oh oh my god the mustache yeah i shaved
it you know you could really start
smelling the day you know you wake up
like today i woke up this morning i
could still smell five guys and what i
had for dinner well zz top found a
missing child did they
they just weighed their mustache
yeah
it's funny because there's a project we
have a new giant projector out there
we've done these sort of developments
and uh i was watching on it feels like
it's 50 feet it's giant and i swear to
you i saw his mustache we were watching
a clip and then i had a nightmare of it
chasing me my mustache
on a big jumbotron it's terrifying it's
funny i woke up it's just not there
chasing me like where'd it go
that's what happened he's like i have to
say i shaved it yeah we're doing a
little sketch today so i had to i wanted
to be authentic doesn't that suck we
have to shave our beards and mustaches
all because we do this for you yeah yeah
my club it's a big surprise i grew that
all july and i got to get rid of it for
you he's
july he's been growing that since last
september okay it was just last year
right now after the raid on president
trump we had to double check turns out
this guy is real because i know you'll
think that we're we're faking something
it's real this is a real liberal from
what if and if i'm wrong you guys can
admonish me i've done all of my due
diligence it seems this is a real person
uh the left is of course counting their
crazy chickens the crazy chickens before
they hatch oh boy the fbi is scanning
fingerprints on every classified
document that they recovered from donald
trump's safe in mar-a-lago this means
they are going to find out who touched
each document so that they can prosecute
them all this also means that the
documents were so highly classified that
they are worried that who got a whole
lot good beauty and the beast library
security risk i'm wondering where his
question mark suit is
wow get ready because justice is coming
i'm as ugly as a bat
blind as a can you get money from the
government call one eight hundred oh
they're at my house yeah oh jeez
they're here got milk it called 1-800 it
just goes to his residential line do you
remember that peanut butter commercial
where the guy or the milk commercial or
the guy's got peanut butter in his mouth
the radio show calls in it's the ugliest
guy no like do you know the answer to
and he's like
it looks like this guy identical oh wow
well you know so he's he has some
options yeah he could do other crazies
yeah exactly identical look i don't want
to make fun of someone just because
they're heinously unattractive true so
liz cheney lost her primary last night
um
and unrelated news yeah man and she had
all that uh money her dad got from
funding 911.
unless you look into it yeah um tuesday
is what it happened were wednesday today
here's the thing uh
she uh
she lost to a trump back cam trump
trump-backed candidate oh i should lose
by 37 points
by 37 points think about that for a
second 37 points i got some new york
times there kevin uh that's crazy 37
points i don't remember her losing by
37. 37
points
but well she got about 44 000 votes in
the state i believe was roughly the
number and i'm betting around 10 000
were dems that crossed the line in the
primary because you can do that yeah
actually no uh 43 999 joe lewis ah yeah
if you write in you actually lose by 37
points yeah
yeah it's true and she did though
however credit words do give one hell of
a concession speech she's great at those
the great and original champion of our
party abraham lincoln was defeated in
elections for the senate and the house
before he won the most important
election of all
lincoln ultimately prevailed he saved
our union and he defined our obligation
as americans for all of history you know
lincoln later gettysburg of the great
task remaining before us
[ __ ]
that we here she does have her dad's
good looks shall not have died in vain
that this nation under god shall have a
new birth of freedom
and that government of the people by the
people and for the people shall not
perish from this earth
as we meet here tonight that remains our
greatest and most important task
most of world history is a story of
violent conflict
of servitude and suffering
okay were there no people i didn't even
see a head no no you're just the
afterbirth yes
yes no
she recorded that a week ago knowing she
was getting killed
[Laughter]
let me read this because of course it's
a little bit it's a little bit childish
yeah but hysterical i love it that's why
we love it and we also going maybe hold
back a little bit but don't really hold
back please don't president donald trump
uh didn't hold back posting to his truth
social
look here's what i will say hers was
grandiose she started talking about
abraham lincoln and the birth of a
nation and
whatever and then so he responded in a
way that was just as grandiose only
taking a big dump on her yes
this is a this is a wonderful result for
america and a complete rebuke of the
unselect committee
he capitalized it um like it's an actual
official organization right okay a
complete rebuke of the unselect
committee of political hacks and thugs
now she jd case you forgot who i was
talking about shady folks i didn't
now she shady can finally disappear to
the depths of the political oblivion
where
i am sure she will be much happier than
she is right now
thank you wyoming
i love it
i absolutely love it look there's she
can return to the river sticks folks
excuse me where she will be no doubt
more content
a lot more content with the hades played
by james woods
that she is right now
thank you america by the way abraham
lincoln
not a fan of you liz not a fan of what
you do i've talked to her
no i mean everybody hated this person
because she joined a sham committee for
january yes and made it seem like you
had to go after donald trump for trying
to overthrow the government when he
didn't do that we've called out trump
when he was of course we've criticized
trump plenty of times and by the way
people act as though you have to be a
complete lackey for donald trump
otherwise you're removed it's just not
true no you can comment below mo i'm
willing to bet that most of you
probably have some issues with donald
trump think that he has some
shortcomings and then also appreciate
him for what he is that's what we are
the problem is that she sided with the
enemy always and like you said has taken
part being complicit in a sham trial
claiming it was the most violent day in
our history yeah while draping the
american flag over her shoulders and
saying i'm trying to save democracy no
you're actually not this is not what
you're making it out to be and by the
way guess who agrees
almost everyone in wyoming who voted yes
i was gonna say you're running in
wyoming where did you think you were
running yeah it's wyoming
who did you think your constituents were
yeah and she she might this is there's a
rumor she might she might run for
president she's hinting at it right now
please do i hear it's easier to get
votes that way
in wyoming alone matthew shepherd will
vote 48 000 times
i hope that donald trump decides to run
just to take a giant steaming dump on
liz and then drops out of the race i
guarantee you he will if she runs the
only reason for doing it it would be
hilarious
oh my gosh unreal imagine them on a
debate stage oh yeah oh uh liz it was
just forty four thousand people
it would just be like she would be
sitting like well you know in january
six maybe like lesbian oh no
yeah
oh no does that word mean anything
i'm just saying i'm just saying the word
doesn't mean anything to me
what does lesbian mean to you or dick
dick that's my dad i know
yeah
so uh look we also have the over under
you can comment on
how soon she'll be working for the view
as their newest republican panelist
but right now of course look
worthy political adversary we'd like to
offer a proper send-off to
uh liz cheney which brings us to liz
cheney's time to close today we face a
threat america has never seen before
donald trump
[Music]
trump's legal team donald trump
president trump's a threat posed by
donald trump and donald trump but donald
trump's because republicans cannot both
be loyal to donald trump
and loyal to the constitution donald
trump cannot escape responsibility that
i will do whatever it takes to ensure
donald trump is never again anywhere
near the oval office liz you're fired
get out of here
i know that it's time for things to
close things too
[Music]
it almost makes me miss her nope no not
really
she was also wearing the same
stuff in the last video yeah she also
tried to boil the trump kid's pet rabbit
yes but
i just think she's recorded the video
many times this is it's the problem when
you're obsessed this is the problem is
these people they say i'm willing to
stand up against but then that's their
only their research
donald trump donald trump she was
obsessed and that didn't work if she
would have said you know what i think
donald trump was wrong about this this
is where i i agree with him on foreign
policy it's a good thing to even start
any new wars this is where i disagree
then let the cards fall where they may
not every single trump-backed candidate
has won just to be clear and not every
single person who's been critical of
donald trump has lost but when you toss
your lot in with january 6th and you are
the ambassador the representative with
this sham trial on television
you shouldn't be mad when republicans
don't elect you you deserve what you get
and i think she's probably going to be
isn't that really the one of the biggest
problems too with politics is just i
don't like this person and that's your
entire campaign right that it's just
comical exactly yeah well adam
kensington took the uh coward's way out
and retired i wish you would have run
adam i wanted to see that yeah screw
that guy by the way uh it's a live show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
and uh you know we're not i have no one
has more enemies i don't think in the
like republican movement than my for
someone who's a conservative a lot of
people not big fans of so the only way
we get to sustain this is if you joined
mud club lighters.com club monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern you can
tune in we'll do a full other show today
another hour-long show it's almost a
completely different show today 10 a.m
eastern notifications don't work tune in
okay
let's get to the department of education
all right uh i think we need to
completely defund the federal part the
department of education yes not saying
it's just you know we're going with the
theme because defund the fbi defund the
doj i think it could defund most
branches of the government but most of
you and i know i can hear especially a
lot of mothers like oh what am i going
to do i don't know you see what
homeschool people god you might have to
be a parent now
we don't need it we all think we need it
but let me be clear if you do away with
the federal department of education it
would affect public schools in your
state likely zero yeah your p let me set
the stage here your parents right now if
you're in my generation or younger okay
so millennials gen z
your parents all went to school before
there was a department of education at
least started
school before a federal department of
education
it's 1979
when it was signed into law public
schools existed well before 1979. by the
way test scores reading math scores
they've either stagnated or fallen what
does this mean this is something you
need to understand how does that happen
schooling is largely funded by the
states before the federal department of
education was almost entirely funded by
the states and the bulk of it is still
coming from the states we do not need a
federal department of education for you
to have decent schools and it comes with
a lot of strings attached and a lot of
union baggage that you cannot shed
within your state as effectively as you
could if we did not have the federal
department of education we don't need
the federal department of education it
is it is unbelievably expensive and it's
made schools worse marley was dead to
begin with anything there you guys good
okay 100 agree i got you since 2000 no
child left behind okay that's everyone
blamed bush for that didn't really work
common core none of this is working no
at a certain point you have to take
inventory and say it's not working so
what do we need to do one side says
spend more money more money more money
more money please i'm saying no money
not more money none
and the states just get to keep that
money instead of sending it to the
federal government to fund the
department of education who then turns
around and dulls it out to whoever they
want exactly yeah so we'll just do that
we'll keep it so let's start we're going
to go through
something that happened in minneapolis
then we're going to go through the
national teachers union what's happened
in florida and then close with some
information sort of on a national level
regarding a public school so this is a
theme today because i know that there
are a lot of parents out there concerned
especially in the post-covert world yeah
you know because what are we going to do
with the true heroes
so those are nurses yes that's right the
dance now the good ones they tick-tock
nurses it's a verb they don't dance they
tick-tock oh tick-tock yeah make that
body exotic tick-tocking yeah
it's pronounced erotic now
march 25th uh this is the minneapolis
federation of the teachers ratified a
collective bargaining agreement okay
with the minneapolis public school
system
what could go wrong in minneapolis
here's part of the deal
if accessing a teacher who is a member
of let me just tell you before i explain
it read the technical jargon they're
going to fire white teachers first yes
okay
so yeah because we've talked about
people say this is racist that's racist
i think if you fire someone
because of their race
call me
i think that's racist
yeah i don't i don't see that no no no
no steven you're wrong that's that's
right how it works well you know what i
agree to disagree i believe it's not
racist okay and now i understand where
you line up thanks for the air support
glad seeing that
cavalry coming over the hill
friendly fire much okay so they're going
to fire white people first this is how
they describe it if accessing a teacher
who is a member of a population
underrepresented among licensed teachers
in the site the district shall access
meaning get rid of fire why do they the
next least senior teacher who is not a
member of an underrepresented population
okay that means white white white white
white yes
so yes you're gonna be fire it's gonna
be a white guy go ahead every single
person and if they're going to be
rehired it is also going to go to a
population that's underrepresented
according to them which is black people
primarily but it also if you went to a
historically black college a tribal or
historically hispanic college as well
you will get rehired first for no reason
most of them go by seniority which i
think is stupid i don't know maybe we
should go by merit maybe we should fire
bad teachers when we have a budget cut
and be like hey you suck get out i don't
care if you've been here a year or a
decade you're a better teacher you get
to stay let me give you a little bit of
a personal the best teacher i ever had i
don't know if she's still alive uh i i
hope that she is if you're watching mrs
naidu fourth grade
i i've talked about this i had to go to
french school because i was in quebec
and my mom is french canadian and so i
had to go to french school where at
least half of my day was in french all
the way through the fourth grade and i
started falling behind where they
thought maybe this kids [ __ ] that
still may be but what it really turned
out is i couldn't do math and i couldn't
do geography and history and french i
can speak french i can read and write
french but learning everything in french
put me behind a little bit so they
switched me midway through my fourth
grade year
and at this point they'd already done
long division and i couldn't learn it
because it was being taught in french
and mrs naidu was an indian teacher
indian canadian teacher
heavy accent stern people were afraid of
her she was very strict she stayed after
class until i learned long division and
aced my test nice a teacher's goal
should be every student gets an a at the
end of the year yeah that should be the
standard standardize a test every
student get the more of your students
who get a's
if they start at 70 percent they start
with a c they end with an a or 100
congratulations you're a good teacher so
she was a minority she was the best
teacher
never even crossed my mind at that point
but that's when we grew up in a
post-racial america in canada you know
where fresh prince and family matters
were the top shows before we segregated
everything with b-e-t and fragmented all
of culture and media and demanded
segregated school spaces this is when we
didn't really think about it we kind of
grew up in a in a wonderful golden era
where of course he had individual
racists but it was largely a thing of
the past systemically and now it's come
back we're more racist than ever well
how did that happen and of course who's
going to save the day the minneapolis
teachers union so
minneapolis public schools have defended
this agreement publicly saying that it
will quote remedy the continuing effects
of past discrimination ah
this is like you know abram candy has
talked about this he's the director of
the center for anti-racist research it's
to undo previous racism you need to do
really racist [ __ ] moving forward yes
i've seen his book in every airport yes
yeah it's next to the newsweek with
trump in prison yes
on the same week that uh you know
muhammad ali died and he was going to
cover everything and uh gordy howe far
more accomplished in his sport nothing
oh yeah just a footnote well and you
said gordy who yeah
like the pig from the city no ah played
with three generations gordy howe look
him up he's he played old yeah well i
remember saying that magazines muhammad
ali muhammad ali muhammad they won't
tell you that he endorsed ronald reagan
campaign for orrin hatch and rejected
all of his segregationist views later in
life once he died they wanted to
venerate him as the guy who dodged the
draft there was a lot more to muhammad
ali than that anyway i met him and ted
lindsay not muhammad ali because corey
howe a uh jets pizza unbelievable guy my
dad spent some time with him super nice
super nice down to earth stayed in the
community all right as opposed to
muhammad ali who left and i said why did
you leave for the suburb he said to get
away from black people that's a quote
you can go read it yeah once he really
started getting that cte he let a lot of
stuff out of his mouth
no but before that he said i was wrong
about that i was wrong about uh you know
calling everyone a house house n-word or
trashing joe lewis trashing joe frazier
he said i was wrong about talking you
know he was against race mixing just to
be clear yeah he said i was wrong about
a lot of that indoor store and hatch
okay yeah malcolm x said that too and
that ended well yeah exactly right
something without someone with our
intelligence agencies right i can't
remember what i don't know yeah
they did something once he decided peace
was the answer so candy wrote this how
to be an anti-racist the only remedy to
racist discrimination is anti-racist
discrimination
the only remedy to pass discrimination
is present discrimination the only
remedy to present discrimination is
future discrimination so basically
the only way to fix bad stuff that's
happened is doing more bad stuff the
only way to fix racism and evil is more
evil i i kind of always thought that we
were raised with this as kids
where you know you were supposed to be
above it yeah yeah absolutely but if you
read that again he actually says to fix
past you need present racism right and
to fix present you need future so
essentially we'll have
racism forever exactly is this thing
it's not like racism enough to where
it's like okay now the ledger is clear
right and we're even let's start again
it's like it's like inception of racism
if you plan on having future racism then
what's the point of even discussing it
because therefore there's no problem to
fix there is no problem that's just the
norm
by the way right
oh come on
oh landler you can keep watching this
snoozefest i've had it i'm going to take
the easy way out no not before you drew
me in first krautoff
murder suicide it is
damn
what i knew i should have gotten the
walter what kind of gun is that well
it's a 22 and it's brand gerald a wow
those only shoot blanks
okay come on now that's not fair he has
two kids it doesn't that doesn't even
make sense he has two kids oh yeah i'm
sure they're really his and not the pool
boys
i don't even have a pool that doesn't i
don't have a pool he doesn't have a pool
why is his van always in your driveway
[Laughter]
walther works i never liked him
there you go all right
i don't know why we installed that
balcony
i mean you've really spent a lot yeah
it was like baseline budgeting if i
don't spend it then i don't get it for
myself next year i know well
it's a puppet too i don't think he's
dead by the way while we're talking
about this teachers are the real heroes
because uh they uh have to bring have
you heard they have to bring some of
their work home with them oh do they
yeah and they have to buy pencils
occasionally i know
i i don't know about you as a business
owner gerald i my my work stops when i
walk out of this office oh yeah never
think about it again and by the way
walther uh official firearm sponsor of
lottery with crowder studios show them
that there gerald uh right now their new
firearm the pdp is unbelievable it has
these new they call them super terrain
slides right it just means it's really
easy to grab it's really easy to rack
the slide go to waltherarms.com
uh to shop online or use a dealer look
all i ask try the walther go to go to
your local firearm range where you can
responsibly try it run a search on
youtube right now if you're on youtube
run a search comment below run a search
on google bing netscape navigator i have
no idea ask jeeves you won't find a bad
review no it's one of the best kept
secrets because they don't have a giant
military contracts like some of the
other big boys well and you can also aim
left-handed and hit the target every
time
zambidextrous with muppets we've had
several friends buy them because of this
show no complaints yeah uh we've had a
lot when we do it to live shows and i
mentioned well the audience goes like
i'm like oh yeah i put them away
no it's not it's not like a lighter
header
in here i always feel pretty protected
yeah well we have to some of these by
the way at some of the live shows
sometimes you cannot carry firearms to
the live shows because it's either venue
policy or someone threatened to kill me
so we're like not tonight no
let's move on down with education it's a
themed episode like you get on some of
those shows where it's like flashbacks
only we're covering this from stem to
stern uh ron desantis the pimp
uh decided to also take some new
initiatives uh for education and it is a
problem we're not getting as many people
going into teaching yeah now the left
will tell you
the left will tell you that we need to
fix that with more money
i don't know if you know this and it's
not going to fix anything so ron
desantis and i think he's really good at
reverse engineering problems and trying
to come up with solutions there are
issues
i have
my
apprehensions about him in some ways but
he is pretty good at saying okay how can
we try and actually solve this issue and
i think that is something that is sorely
needed solutions coming from the right
as opposed to just saying no i don't
like you so some new initiatives aimed
at attracting new teachers in florida
and he's gone with an angle that makes a
lot of sense again if you understand
historically you didn't always need a
degree in teaching you know no you have
a degree in english my ex-girlfriend's
uh mother was a teacher when i was in
college and she had an english degree
said you want to be a teacher she said
sure she was a fantastic teacher so his
plan is uh actually involving recruiting
veterans so like two birds with one
stone
no it's not what is wrong today
recruiting retired military veterans
we also want to include
first responders law enforcement emts
paramedics firefighters who have their
bachelor's degree to become teachers and
bring their leadership and wisdom into
the classroom and what we will do
just like we do for veterans we will do
for the other first responders we will
waive the exam fees for the state seat
state teacher certification exam and if
you do sign up under this program
those teachers will be eligible for a
four thousand dollar bonus to be able to
serve and
if they teach courses that have really
acute shortages uh in those subject
matters they'll get another thousand
dollars and so that'll be a five
thousand dollar bonus uh for first
responders who go in uh to those so
replace the real heroes public teachers
with non-heroes veterans and first
responders you mean people that run
quackery danger
and you can comment below i'll get into
the details of this what you think about
that because the left is saying you
can't just do the spring and veterans
they have ptsd they're going to mustard
gas the whole classroom
um here's what will actually happen okay
so let me read you some details from the
program uh military veterans who passed
this teaching exam eligible for a
temporary certificate as long as they
have they meet these qualifications four
years or more of active duty honorable
service
60 college credit hours yeah that's an
associate's degree by the way that's two
years and they get a teacher
apprenticeship program you know a
scholarship uh to help current high
school teachers earn their masters so
there's a lot going on here by the way
and the the
this is also something we need to
rethink how we approach t this is a very
new concept that you have to have a
degree in teaching yeah so you can you
know show a bunch of kids how to be
lesbians it's not really the
qualification that you need you just
need to be someone who can impart wisdom
oh uh jared well so you had you have to
pass the the the test right so he said
in a subject matter test to be able to
teach this subject you have to have your
associate's degree but you also have to
serve as a an apprentice with another
teacher who has been there i think it
was at least seven years and highly
rated teacher they give that person a
mentor bonus so it's not like they're
just turning them loose on a class
they're giving you on-the-job training
for i believe it's two years before
you're let go on go go do your thing now
as a teacher but you also still have to
finish your bachelor's degree right why
would anybody in the world be against
this there is no reason i can see go
ahead i was going to say one thing that
he does better than most he solves the
problem and he does it with maximum piss
off the left mentality yeah he really
just laces that in there so that if they
go against it it is just completely
obvious well i think the only people who
might oppose it are maybe some sort of
new conservative libertarians who
don't understand federalism and say i
oppose increased spending well this is
the thing states should be able to
increase spending on education if they
want to but i understand we now have the
problem of if ron desantis is increasing
spending on education which he is to a
very large degree
combined with the bloated federal budget
it's a problem that's why we need to
eliminate the federal department of
education i don't have a problem with
states right allocating funds they have
the right to do that so of course his
opponent but can they come in with a
crippling headache and press play on a
dvd if they're a woman okay
he's 20 his likely speaking of which uh
his 2022 opponent nikki freed
uh
known by the the common uh nomenclature
certain loser
there's no way she stands a chance i
wouldn't think so so she's the the liz
cheney this is the liz cheney of liz
cheney's of liz right basically i guess
that's true oh my god said uh let me be
clear we should not be lowering the bar
for teachers in florida there's a
there's a swipe at veterans instead of
paying teachers what they're worth and
agreeing to stop politicizing their jobs
it's not rocket science they always say
this when they're about to say something
that's really dumb it's not rocket
science hold on a second are you about
to say something that's really stupid
maybe it needs to be rocket science yeah
by the way how are you teaching rocket
scientists teaching them about racial
inequities oh thank god you guys are
building our planes it's not rocket
science we have a teacher shortage
crisis because desantis has turned
classrooms into battlegrounds to fight
his culture wars and divide our states
lie
la la la
all not the opposite it's not true at
all
desantis increased
teacher pay funding in march by the way
250 million dollars all references today
and i think this will be very useful for
you going forward or if you want to
refute it 250 million dollars right in
march all references are available at
lightworkscript.com the pay for teachers
in florida increased from 40 000 to 47
000 that makes florida that's the
starting pay to be clear
making florida the ninth highest in the
nation starting pay you start your job
at 47 000 by the way you don't have to
work three months out of the year and
you get a lot of benefits that's not a
bad gig why do they it's not a money
thing people don't go into teaching for
a lot of different reasons it's not just
because of money some of them do some of
them that's why they're complaining
about the money well
that's the only reason some of them come
in no it's because this system is a
bloated failed system why would you go
work for a company that's going down
yeah why would i throw my lot in with
something if people thought that way we
wouldn't have any federal employees well
that's true
first day with a teacher i'm going to be
rich i tell you rich i'll just go do
something else where i can have a chance
to actually succeed basically it's an
indoctrination factory and this is not a
conspiracy theory schools spend think
about it as a parent you spend what 30
minutes with your kids in the morning
before you send them off to school an
hour you get them back in the afternoon
if you work maybe you get them back at
five o'clock you spend a couple of hours
before it's bedtime the school is
spending two to three maybe four times
more time with your kids than you are as
a parent including bedtime and public
school teachers exactly and they're
teaching them crappy stuff right they're
not teaching them the things that they
need to know and
they're filling them with you're not a
fan of drag queen story hour 101 no no
and i'm not i'm not a fan of teaching
them that like crude i know right that
everybody's a purple penguin and he
can't say any of the other things that i
can't say on youtube right now so that i
don't get in trouble i like that well
and you can't but you can't throw ptsd
at these people that's completely bold
especially when you're the you're
teaching a generation of people they
claim they have ptsd because some of
them like misgendered an owl yeah that's
or the problem no it's absolutely and by
the way here's something else too i'm
sorry we're going to go a little bit
because i want to get to why we don't
need the federal department of education
specifically the teachers union but
that's a good point the ptsd thing the
left claims that they want mental health
in this country right the issue is you
constantly politicize it yes right there
are plenty of people with ptsd who are
entirely functioning individuals and by
the way they shouldn't forfeit their
right to a firearm there are plenty of
people in this country who maybe have
depression or bipolar disorder and it
should not disqualify them from their
fundamental human rights so the left
will say we need better hell we need
better mental health care in this
country by the way veterans well this
could be a problem with them teaching
kids by the way oh you took some zoloft
at one point you shouldn't be able to
own a firearm well why do you think that
men don't want to get help because of
this because of these kinds of attacks
that are taking place right now and
you're absolutely right this is a
problem in anger nothing helps the
exactly
let's toss on top of that divorce laws
where you forfeit your rights and
everything becomes public record like
johnny depp right right any guy look at
that and say i won't have to go through
that
no nobody wants a turd in their bed no
no why do you want to turn their backs
nobody who knew the end game was
them finding out your wife did that i
mean maybe you'd go through it yeah but
other than that no well here's the two
birds with one stone thing too vets
former police officers firefighters arm
them
get them in schools so that they can
protect kids if they want to and undergo
special training to make sure that
they're ready to answer the call solved
a lot of problems that's absurd what we
should do is not arm them then once
there's an active shooter scenario send
in the people who are armed to stand
there and wait retroactively with
shields well not stand there and wait
it's to push away the parents that are
trying to keep oh yeah yeah that's true
tackle them yes yeah they watch mystic
river as a training manual
so
all right two people are going to
understand that right well i appreciated
the reference pretty dark it's dark it's
dark but it's pretty accurate yeah um
this is also something by the way like
you mentioned oh they don't go and they
don't go in thinking they're going to be
rich that's true but there are a lot of
people who think that teaching is an
easy path i think it's an easy path
because they can go and make good money
where they're comfortable at some point
get tenure maybe at some point they end
up with all of these benefits they're
based they get put in a rubber room if
they're completely incompetent as
opposed to being fired there are a lot
of people who don't seek to become
incredibly wealthy but they want to make
significantly more than the national
average even if they're not very
qualified they say okay what job doesn't
require intense qualifications or
performance reviews i know teaching
and i got three months off so let's get
to this now the teachers union
which is a problem look at their
political donations we've done a whole
segment on that uh randy weingarten is a
president of the american federation of
of teachers aft for short
i'm just saying it because i don't have
to say this every time and by the way
you're about to see a clip
it is exactly what you expect the
president of the american federation of
teachers to look like picture picture
the broad in your mind right now okay
yes
so appeared on yahoo finance
just grimace to right now bemoan the
current teacher shortage in america
here's the clip what you have is
you have a higher number of retirements
this year it's like age paul mccartney
circa wings years it's a really really
hard year it's will ferrell playing
janet arena more people going into the
profession
you have a hot labor market where
teachers can get 20 more for the skills
and knowledge they have teaching in
non-teaching jobs
you have um all of the pandemic stress
and strain particularly that
kids are coming in with
greater needs because of two years of
disruption
and you know the condition not only have
the conditions not really changed but
you know school districts and the
federal government and others just you
know pretend as if there was no pandemic
and then you have all of the people yes
that's the problem with this
administration denying the pandemic
shaming and blaming the banning of books
the censoring of curriculum so kill
mockingbird teachers are you know they
wonder and i'll give you an example
so many teachers said to me
if a kid asked them a question after the
buffalo mass shooting
if they were in florida or texas they
didn't know whether they could answer
the question that the shooter was a
white supremacist ah there you go by the
way she's going to be pardoned at
thanksgiving here's the thing that
teachers do
they act as though they're the only ones
okay they go you know no we haven't you
know the pandemic which of course you
think you're the only ones who lived
through that no no the only difference
is you're the only ones who got two
years teaching from home right two years
let's let's take the short end of it a
year and a half at most places
don't have three semesters okay no
everyone else had to go to work we never
got to stop work comment below right now
if you're i want to hear from teachers
below public school teachers private
school teachers and those who work in
the private sector and does anyone
actually buy this for a second that this
administration was who didn't really
acknowledge the pandemic are you out of
your trees
by the way when you claim that kids are
coming back and they've had two years of
disruption who was protesting to make
sure that they stayed home during this
time well the white supremacists who by
the way don't want her teaching that the
buffalo shooter was uh was was white hey
didn't something happen in milwaukee
what about waukesha can we teach the
race of those people what about the vast
majority of terrorist attacks
all throughout the globe can we use that
by the way i call bs on that i really do
this is like one of those things i i
would have voted for if you had a penis
right that we covered the other day it
just didn't happen right it was obvious
this was a white supremacist shooter he
had there was no doubt that this guy was
racist right right off the bat no
teacher would have a problem unless
they're an idiot answering that question
for their kids well she would have a
problem answering a question as to the
time
so well i just think the two-year break
was great for mental health and teaching
our young to socialize you know i think
you're absolutely right because look we
can't expect the true heroes to go back
after two years when there's a slight
cough remaining hey i'm wondering what
was i'm not going to quote it but what
was the death rate from zero to 19 from
covid to date i don't even want to say
it because youtube could label
misinformation and by the way of course
youtube doesn't work uh in cahoots with
the federal government in any capacity
who by the way never do not uh have an
undue uh beholden if that's a word i
know it's not uh to teachers unions
so let's go through the claims that are
made just in that video it's like
just i'm just awash with [ __ ]
first claim
that she makes
okay and this will play some other clips
so you see it echoed this is what's
being taught everywhere and these people
get all of your money
your taxpayer dollars
regardless of whether you agree with
them or not that's it really is a
beautiful sham
uh one of the claims that teachers are
not allowed they're not free right now
to teach these controversial issues
meaning
their bias in the classroom this is the
new uh
cause du jour here's another one talking
it's very troubling time to be a teacher
we are faced with
being asked to violate our own
ethical position in that fact should be
tell me about your ethical position
daria
and
on the other side
being required to teach things that are
uh factually inaccurate by omission so
they're looking for us to avoid teaching
things like the fact that the united
states or the state of new hampshire has
had systemic racism in its
laws its
culture
um
things that were enforced both legally
and socially and they have banned our
ability to speak to those things with
our students
and the penalty for that is losing our
teaching license ah okay yes because
many people are losing their teaching
licenses uh for being too liberal
new hampshire what she's watched josh
like i haven't seen a black mayor emily
so
that's her claim here's the truth
yeah here's the truth
republican governors and conservatives
across this country have there's been
backlash and they've enacted laws
precisely because teachers across the
country have been pushing divisive
factually incorrect
far left curriculum like critical race
theory yeah let me give you a few
examples we've done entire segments on
this i'm sure you can hit a link in the
description along with all the
references in oregon schools pushed uh i
just forgot remember this term it always
makes me laugh before i go into a blind
rage ethno mathematics ah
what what
what oh
mathematics ethno
mathematics
that's no mathematics to undo white
supremacy
in math
hmm
yes no they're being fired they're being
fired for 99.9
of their donations going to democrats
you're not being fired for being a blue
dog moderate democrat you're cheat
you're teaching ethno mathematics
it's the stupidest thing i've ever heard
of in my life shouldn't it be a
beautiful thing that math
is completely blind
yeah
largely because it's on a paper it has
no eyes we just use calculators please
what
so here's i don't i don't want to bring
anything to a screeching halt
uh what yeah what is ethno mathematics
it's about mathematics and something
something something racism yes white
supremacy so like white supremacy plus
two equals doubly bad equal science give
me more money well dave paper is white
and you do math on paper well that's why
i use white pencils i don't know if i
buy it though because you're technically
dominating a white paper with a black
sharpie so the point is it evens out i
feel that way too in decatur georgia the
district's equity plan uh encourages
teachers to quote normalize racial
equity the list goes on and on and on
you have references that you can come uh
you can go and read or
come to light earthquaker.com and read
them we make them all publicly available
so the lady on that clip i just want to
make this very clear the problem that
they have with you is that you're
teaching that systemic racism existed
the problem isn't that you point out
specific instances of racism and say
well hold on a second i need to correct
you you said of course systemic racism
existed what you mean is existing now
now in new hampshire yeah exactly right
so just pointing that out and saying
like oh it's no it's still now all the
laws that we have are racist and that's
what's holding you back not pointing out
system systems that maybe had some
racist tendencies to begin with and now
have been corrected well i have to
correct something because i didn't
change my mind i said there is no
systemic systemic racism changed my mind
i was wrong there are systemically
racist laws like what you just saw in
minneapolis exactly where they're going
to fire white teachers i would say
that's systemically racist that's true
accessing them they're accessing them
yes yes but i thought we were supposed
to pull down statues and pretend racism
didn't happen i didn't know excess was a
verb no it didn't happen but we'll make
it happen now
so and by the way let's not uh forget uh
the attempts to sexualize young children
uh which i'm sure you're well aware of
but you know hey look
sorry
not that laughing at
that just take a look it's on a [ __ ] and
a reading rainbow oh rain i can't touch
anything
it's a magic school bus just me and you
yeah okay i knew i should have stayed
home today
now look it i'm making myself disappear
in you yes
[Music]
there's a disproportionate number of
teachers for as much as people go after
the catholic church and by the way they
should go after the clergy when these
gross abuses happen and they're covered
up
happens far more often in public schools
sexual abuse of children happens a lot
all right here's another truth for you
okay she talks about the shortage
and we've discussed this uh before
uh the shortage here the teacher
shortage
so largely and this isn't the original
article on yahoo yeah
it's in liberal and west coast states
now let me explain to you why that
matters this is from that yahoo article
where you saw the original video of
randy weingarten
bon jovi yes
the states struggling to find teachers
the most are mainly near the west coast
with the top five being california
nevada washington arizona and hawaii so
think about this for a second
if we're talking
let's all can we all acknowledge of
course that
public teachers lean left yeah as a
demographic okay and i'm not just
talking about the union that gives all
of their money to democrats that's fair
yeah but the vast majority of public
school teachers
are liberal white [ __ ] okay now
where would a liberal white woman which
is the typical or liberal white man or
liberal black woman a public school
teacher where do you think they would be
more happy in general in a place like
california in a school district and
let's say los angeles san francisco
bakersfield take your pick or
ultra right christian rural oklahoma yet
yet yet these teachers are leaving in
higher numbers from liberal states where
the kinds of laws that they're
complaining about are not being enacted
at all at all as a matter of fact their
curriculum is being encouraged it's the
other way yeah to be more progressive
and by that i mean racist so this is the
question we have a teacher shortage it
shouldn't be happening in california
shouldn't be happening in washington
shouldn't be happening in hawaii
now what's the solution here i will uh
let's let's find some common ground
remember the fairness doctrine i do okay
so the fairness doctrine it was
something that was uh it was a while
back and i think uh what was happening
it was abolished in 87 i believe uh but
they tried to bring it back with uh
remember air america was this failed uh
left-wing am radio this is what happened
the modern iteration of fairness
doctrine has been going on for a long
time but because the left wasn't happy
having abc nbc cbs cnn and all of fm
radio they saw someone like rush
limbaugh sean hannity and fox news they
saw it as a threat and they said oh my
god
you can't do that because you're kicking
our asses so we need to enact a law
where you have to provide exactly equal
time right on the news if you provide a
conservative point of view you have to
provide a liberal point of view now of
course what was wrong with this is they
thought that people like walter cronkite
dan rather brian williams were my god
journalists so they wouldn't have to
balance themselves out but someone like
rush limbaugh will then have to provide
just as much time uh with a liberal
point of view even though he's in
basically uh a radio op-edsman so that
was the fairness doctrine it was absurd
of course as it relates to broadcasting
the federal government should have no
say in what you broadcast okay that
should be left up to the individual
broadcasting companies however as it
relates to teaching here if you're
complaining that you cannot teach
children that the buffalo shooter was a
white supremacist how about we have some
kind of a fairness doctrine in schools
you want to teach ethnomathematics okay
you also have to teach that the evil
white western european nations ended
slavery and created the electricity and
modern uh educational system that you
enjoy
that sounds fair just give some equal
time yeah
you want to teach that we had slavery
here in this country of course you of
course you can of course you should it's
a black dot
you have to teach who sold those slaves
and that they still are selling slaves
how about that are you saying teach
facts i'm saying teach even if you want
to give opinion give both sides of it so
how about is that something we could do
a fairness doctrine for education why
should it apply to sean hannity's am
radio show and not to the people who
spend eight hours a day with your kids
comment below does that seem like
something we can all be on board with i
am i'd vote for you
if you're gonna teach buffalo teach
waukesha also while we're at it teach
the empirical crime statistics break
them up by race
yeah
okay
so here's another claim that they make
and this is again why we need to uh d
we need to defund the federal department
of education
and this is going to be rough so i warn
you guys just don't don't let your rage
get the better of you
the teachers and you heard it before and
i'll play another clip so you know it's
not just one lone [ __ ] wolf
teachers felt
unsafe because of covid after 16 years
tracy riggs is saying goodbye to the
classroom this letter is what she turned
in after school and a decision she said
she had to make
no circumstance should it be okay that
our kids are getting sick
in no circumstance should this be okay
tracy would you get sick at your house
immune system says walking away from the
classroom is her only option
i have to take care of myself at this
point being immunocomp please do and not
having support
with the higher-ups who make the
decisions she says after a recent
exposure at school he had been tested
for kova the day before came to school
before his results came out she's on the
streets and found out he was positive
right after my class the line was drawn
and the decision was made i shouldn't
have to be scared to come to work in
this day and age
i
shouldn't be afraid because no one's
supporting me right now this is the
problem right here i shouldn't have to
be scared guess what we can't control
your irrational fears did you listen to
that story
did you listen to that story the problem
was one of the students i believe i
can't remember was a student or teacher
one of the students tested and then came
into school before realizing that the
test was positive which means that this
is such a deadly pandemic for children
the kid didn't even know he had it and
you're huddling under the bed like it's
where the wild things are for cry it's
not my responsibility to make sure that
you're not afraid
you're an adult
and here's the truth objectively that's
just opinion objectively public school
teachers you all know this i don't even
feel like i need to provide a reference
had far more absurd precautions tying
coddling away from school zoom calls and
they didn't want to come back because
they could do their job without pants
which they often do in classrooms anyway
so long as there are no cameras running
yeah gerald i love it so she's saying
that she's immunocompromised and that's
a real thing i understand that but
you're working in a school being you
know compromised it doesn't take covet
19 for you to have a problem yeah it's
like working in the premier ward and you
find babies gross yes it's like i need
to probably remove myself from the
situation but by the way unless we
jumped into the delorean and went to the
future that video was actually shot last
september
if i remember correctly we had a vaccine
and several booster shots available by
that time that she could have taken and
availed herself of if she wanted to keep
said teaching job you can four boost
yourself into testing positive like jill
biden she could do this is the best
thing you can come into the real world
where we didn't get the opportunity to
close down because of kobe because by
god we can't take two years off and stay
in business like public schools and
still be under threat of getting covet
being immuno-compromised there is no
safe space i'm sorry that's not how the
world works hey by the way you could
just get covered like everyone did hey
guys careful how you careful how you
talk to the real heroes i'm sorry yeah i
shouldn't have said that i i hope you
don't get covered no because your
chances are there's no kid at school
that did the exact same thing right yeah
exactly just go somewhere else no one
handed you an apple that the entire
classroom had licked licked it yes look
if you want to argue if white privilege
is real or not you just saw it yeah no i
think
right but still that is a at least a
first world privilege well it's it's
white female privilege for sure i
shouldn't have to go to work scared oh
oh oh sorry yeah unlike the non-you're a
real hero you don't want to go to work
scared unlike the non-heroes who are you
know entrenches
who could die when they go to work oh
i'm the real hero i don't want to go i
shouldn't look i shouldn't ever have to
be scared
i want tenure so here's my solution
you're getting shot at you're like i
think i feel a chill yeah exactly
yeah they're not coughing because of a
virus they're coughing because they're
inhaling gunpowder and the sweet smell
of mustard gas need to find private ryan
he's got a cold yes
patient zero
just walk up to the porch to deliver the
news
here's his nasal afrin my god
don't box send him here don't send him
back
why would you have chores to do yes is
he wearing a mask so here's why
that's a tom hanks at the end instead of
shooting his colt for shooting is a 45
at a tank he's just putting on a mask he
needs his masks
yeah okay well you know what he was a
teacher yeah yeah he was
he went to war he was a real hero when
he was at home yeah when he went to you
know he was just a [ __ ] yeah well yeah
yeah
i shouldn't have to be scared guys
they're shooting they're shooting at us
guy back home i'm a hero out here i'm
just a pansy guys okay
here's the solution this one's easy fire
teachers who won't fall in line with
reasonable precautions similar to what
every other industry has had to take
why do we allow this bubble to exist of
public school teachers
where there's a different standard that
applies to them and we act as though
they're the real heroes and oh my gosh i
can't believe well we can't expect them
to work uh you know two months out of
the summer or christmas oh my gosh we we
can't expect them to take work home
everybody else does all of those things
it's like guys are you making less than
the national average no we're making
more oh is your job performance better
than the national average for people no
it's really bad people talk about it
they throw money at us constantly they
still do a
[Laughter]
job
you are snippy today gerald i like it
this is this is one of my biggest pet
peeves the public education system and
teachers that go out there and do crappy
jobs there's some good teachers that of
course sure system this year absolutely
sucks and needs to be
dismantled down to the studs completely
gone i'm tired of teachers complaining
and then doing stuff like this and and
by the way
excess the hell out of them i'll use
your term just to make sure that you
guys understand
the reason that we don't fire them is
because of teachers unions and tenure
tenure is a crappy policy that should be
ended sorry yep no i think you're
absolutely right which brings us too
that's good you're foreshadowed oh there
we go good good for you mr
steiner it's another claim that they're
making uh that teachers need higher
wages and they'll make a verifiably
false claim because your instinct is to
oh teachers aren't paid enough you're
wrong
they say that pay has not gone up enough
and actually lie about it here's another
person walk out
of course everyone feels underpaid
but teachers grievances are grounded in
reality
that's a weird way to phrase it their
salaries have fallen compared to workers
with similar levels of education your
fears are not real it's a phenomenon
researchers call the teacher pay gap and
it's grown from about three percent in
the mid-90s
almost 19 in 2017.
what we saw was a lot of teachers being
laid off during the recession across the
country and in many places those funds
have never been reinstituted or opt so
when you have
tight labor markets like we do now
and you start to see wages grow
in the broad private sector we'll see
teacher pay getting worse well thanks
for the expert advice uh skinny drew
carey i love how they say their fears
are grounded in reality like you know
someone had a talk with them beforehand
someone's like come on now this isn't
this isn't reality it's grounded in
reality i'm gonna go do a voiceover that
says just that these are grounded in
reality just say like their fears about
pay this is someone who obviously knows
what the counter argument is about to be
and by the way put on your mouth guard
so this tin can i'm about to kick
doesn't hit you in the teeth because
here comes the truth
when pro rated to an annual salary
taking into benefits uh
taking into account all the benefits
teachers make very decent pay and by the
way if you're watching right now and you
make about average pay here in the
united states teachers make more than
you significantly more than you not
saying they're rich they're not scrooge
mcduck they make good money so let's
look at what their actual salary is the
average salary for a teacher right now
average salary okay we just give you
starting pay in florida starting pay
plus benefits 47 000. average salary for
a teacher right now in the united states
is 65 000.
65.90 is what i have here let's compare
that to united states non-teacher
national average fifty eight thousand
two hundred dollars
okay now that's just salary to salary
that's an actual teacher salary we
haven't created anything yet nothing
average united states teacher works 180
days a year compared to non-teachers
remember how i talked about that there's
the rest of the country and then public
teachers 180 days a year
to everyone else 240 days a year
it's not even close they're making more
money for far less work but some of them
have to buy pencil cases i don't give a
[ __ ]
take some of the extra seven thousand
dollars that you're making for the
what 80 less days 60 less days per year
i'm sure you can find something
somewhere for your felt caterpillar on
your desk isn't it a write-off yes yes
it is by the way in your summer job you
can probably make i don't know the 75
you spend
i would have to work two jobs no no no
no we're not suggesting that you work
two jobs we're suggesting that when your
job stops for two months you work a job
you're still only working a job one job
or
don't
and don't complain and just take your 65
000 a year and shut up
yeah i'd rather you say thank you i just
wouldn't yeah
maybe you just steal some pencils on
break yep
maybe a couple of sharpeners go to a
bunch of hotels
just take pens off desks well today
you'd take ipads so it'd be a nice
little side hustle you can comment if
you like do you actually believe this
have you actually believed that teachers
are not being paid so if you prorate
their salary take it from 180 days a
year and just have them working the
average amount of days 240 which by the
way seems low to me the where we work
here in this in this this show and this
business uh it would be 94 000 a year
wow ninety four thousand dollars if you
were a pro rated if they were to work
all year and be paid
right for the months that they they
don't work
ninety four thousand dollars and by the
way in texas and i think in dallas but
certainly uh in texas there's been
billboards popping up all over the place
showing teacher salaries up to a hundred
and two thousand dollars per year
no one goes into teaching for the money
hey let me ask you this if you were in a
career path where you were making the
average salary of most americans at 58
000 per year do you think that 102 000
might might cause you to reconsider it
just because of money because that's an
issue that we run into with people going
into teaching not all some do go in for
the money and some do go in for the
benefits and for not just that but most
importantly the lack of pressure yeah
stability too yes i mean it's a very
stable job and like they were doing in
florida a lot of a lot of states have
programs where you can get your master's
degree and have it fully paid for
by the schools like this is a pretty
good deal yes for a lot of people and by
the way in that texas thing 102 is the
top 60 was the bottom 60 000 was the
entry point in that article that they
were talking about which is above what
the median wage is in the united states
or the average the average wage you know
significantly above crazy oh oh
i get what i get i get july and i get
august off in december okay well you
voted for the inflation yeah well that's
another that little chart that they
showed that is based on reality uh
here's the truth okay truth number two
no it's not so spending on education in
the last decade well decades but
certainly the last decade let's use the
last two decades as an example because
it can go back forever and just see i
mean that's all of government right they
don't really slash anything once it's in
it's in you're golden your aces and then
it only increases so the spending with
education has increased dramatically
wow
where's the money going miss union
president who you know has teacher fat
you know i mean when they go on the
chalkboard and it's this thing oh no oh
yeah it just erases everything yes
exactly
she's writing the equation on the wall
and it's gone by the time she puts the
chalk down so since 2000 uh the
department of education their spending
has increased by buy take a guess take a
guess take a guess pause this right now
if you're watching if you're watching
live you can't it's bad hit the like
button by the way because this number is
going to surprise you
so hit the like button now
take a pause double it since 2000 they
said which is based in reality teacher
pay has gone underneath a little little
chart
since 2000 spending has increased by 678
well that looks like a line that goes up
where is the money going well that's a
good question let's check into the
unions by the way states like california
and that i believe that same period of
time they've also increased spending by
128 billion dollars new york 65 billion
dollars so lots and lots of money
federally and then of course from the
state like a teacher pay is going down
budget's going down no that's not really
true now it's not all going to the
teachers yeah because it often goes to
the union just like the uae when you
look at why you spend so much of an
american car there's often a pile of
crap well you're paying for three
workers uh three retirees for every
worker who's not actively working
because of the union benefits you were
able to say something in the jails no
okay no no i'm sorry i thought you were
no no i was looking at the money and i
was just floored by how much money we're
spending on it because we've thrown
trillions of dollars over the last
decades i've heard numbers that are
pretty high i don't know exactly how
many trillions of dollars and the line
that went up just a minute ago and how
much we're spending yeah the test score
line does the exact opposite yes goes
down so we're spending more money and
getting less four hours when you give
people a bunch of money with no
performance incentives or no metrics
they have to meet to keep their job
because that would be cruel to the true
heroes
they tend to do a shitty job
i will give no credence to the argument
that teachers are the real heroes and
underpaid now if you're a good teacher
and there are some fantastic teachers i
think you deserve to be paid much more
exactly
i think you should be able to make six
figures if you're an amazing teacher
well
at least in texas well you absolutely
should be able to no i think it would be
great how about we have just
performance-based systems across the
board where you can truly make tons of
money because you're that good at
teaching right people want to get into
your class so let me go through what do
we have here the claims teachers felt
unsafe because of covet okay well that's
complete bullcrap we know that they said
that they're not allowed to teach their
social agenda of course they actually
are allowed to teach their social agenda
they said that teachers wages aren't
going up enough that's complete bull
crap and they're saying that the amount
of spending on education isn't enough
okay we know that's not true let's get
to another one because this is a very
common one that you hear and i believed
for a long time until i did some slight
reading
the claim
that they make
is that smaller class sizes are needed
needed because it impacts that's one of
the most important metrics as it relates
to student performance now i'm not
saying it doesn't matter at all
but what this really means is take the
class divided by two more money please
more money please here's their claim i
have 25 students around 30. 34 children
over 30 kids 33 30
yeah
new york city schools have roughly 15 to
30 percent more students than the rest
of the state
large classes lead to chaotic learning
environments and over-stressed students
and teachers by the way did they just
say it was 20 something students yeah
one of them was like for crying out loud
i went to that was that was not large
for my class where i went and i was in
public schools in canada not long ago i
was well into the 30s i was surprised
they're like oh we have to teach we have
22 kids in it well that's like that's
like a little little house in the
prairie schoolhouse that's not really
that severe no and the girl leaning
against the locker where was that film
the beverly hills high yes exactly no
one has ever sat like that in high
school you get trampled
negative attention all around and there
i have these many students yeah but you
were scared because a student had a
positive covered test so i mean but is
that the reason that you're doing a poor
job teaching good that's the important
thought now we're asking the right
question because here's the truth and uh
john stachel john stotzel actually did a
segment on this a while back well okay
it's false okay the truth is they're
wrong it's not it's not the most
important metric it's not even that
important of a metric because we look at
it in a bubble where we look at public
schools and we go the smaller classes
and public schools do better than the
larger classes in public schools but
they still suck because of public
schools so you have to compare it to
non-public schools and there was a study
done specifically
uh i believe it was in new york we have
it's from the heritage foundation yeah
we can bring it over here catholic
schools especially outperformed public
schools um
and they had much larger class sizes
okay they outperformed them by a
significant amount of uh of
significant uh metrics that they met uh
particularly like math and by the way
black students in catholic schools did
better in math and black students and
smaller class sizes and public schools
so this is actually a quote from that uh
that study catholic schooling in
washington dc had a greater effect on
students than decreasing class size they
did it with 10 more kids on average in
the classroom and by the way 52 of the
kids in those schools were not even
catholic so i know what you're here
you're going like catholics i'm not
catholic but if i were in new york city
i would consider putting my kid in a
catholic school
the catholic schools did something right
they were far more effective for inner
city children you want to help instead
of teaching black kids that all white
people are racist and today they have to
deal with white supremacy how about you
go send them to uh to learn under some
white nuns for a bit and they'll learn
learn that you're full crap right so
this is washington dc is where they got
that from and by the way washington
guess guess who spends just about the
most in the country i think it's in the
top five per pupil yeah on public
schools washington dc i don't know
technically they're not a state well i
don't think there's anything crazy about
a statistic what they're going for if
you teach any kid individually which is
why people have tutors and after class
they pay for there's no surprise there
because you're finding what that kid
learns i mean you and i have talked
about this i didn't learn in the same
way that other kids did right so when i
learned about audio video and i had a
teacher that actually took time to like
show me everything with editing a plus
right and but it was something that i
had interest in and that wasn't the
other teacher's fault but it was
something oh i i like this it was a
systems fault right yeah and once they
find that thing in you that makes you
want to do something and they they
figure that out and some teachers are
able to do that with an entire class
which is incredible yeah it's
i do feel it's kind of few and far
between at this point you're absolutely
right and here's here's a big reason why
you you didn't not learn correctly you
learned and this is the big problem that
nobody wants to talk about you learned
as a boy learns and we just saw it with
how many people did we just see saying
my classroom is too big i can't
shouldn't be expected to go to school
and be scared the public educate
education the public education system
that's not i didn't go through public
education i did but that's not why i
lisped it was just my mouth got drunk
the public educational system is largely
designed by women and certainly today
there's undue influence from women and
they try to teach everyone to learn in
the way that little girls learn study
after study after study shows that
little boys don't learn sitting in a
classroom listening to a teacher it's
why look this is one thing that people
used to when your kids are girls are
smarter no boys are smarter the truth
here's the truth okay
girls do better in school absolutely
they do better in school particularly
grade school high school
boys young men blow them away on the
sats why is that because now they have
an individual tutor they can study at
their own pace they can learn in the
appropriate way that they learn
public education is designed
for young girls and even then it's not
very good particularly if you look at
private schools you look at even options
like montessori schools christian
schools this is where since they are not
beholden to a social engineering
curriculum they can actually spend time
with students regardless of class size
and develop more effective ways of
teaching students and you see that gap
close particularly with young boys and
men because we all know that boys don't
learn by sitting with their hands full
of this why boys like jim and they like
shop and i liked media studies where we
got to cut together videos right that
was my favorite class i didn't want to
sit there and listen to some guy teach
history have you have you tried to learn
canadian history no nobody knows it's
the worst snow it is so boring you know
here in the states you had a
revolutionary war yeah remember that's
kind of a big deal you know what they
did you in canada we said all right and
we put the queen on our money he could
have joined forces with us why had that
automotive in art and i loved all three
of them and those were the ones that
were very you know hands-on i'm showing
you how this works and everything is not
for every kid i'm not saying that they
shouldn't shouldn't necessarily learn
the basics they should
but it goes beyond that to where it's
like look i'm not going to comprehend
algebra i never will stop trying to make
me once you throw in letters i'm like
this is not math it's not no i'm not
dyslexic i just don't like learning this
from an angry lesbian no
you're yelling at me yes
[Laughter]
they you know what the catholic school
also did they set expectations and they
spent the entire time telling them that
they could do it that you are not a
victim unless you're an altar boy if you
were not a victim you were absolutely
able to go forward and solve these
problems and if they don't hit you with
the ruler some incentive there too yeah
they were still a little abusive when i
was there but it was still more verbal
but they deserved it no he's talking
about he's talking about you know
private catholic schools in like
washington dc when i was like real young
i went but not when i was in high school
when i went to public school in quebec
which was catholic school you guys do
the math because it was a state religion
there so that's also a problem first
amendment okay let me give you a
solution here and this one's really
really simple i've never heard an
effective counter argument against it if
you have one comment below i talked with
carrie lake future governor of arizona
most likely about this
so it's a very simple solution and this
is really the most important solution
student vouchers you fund the student
not the school right now you've seen the
increase in spending 670 something
percent
uh since 2000 right you've seen the
increase uh in teacher pay it's not
working you've seen the test results go
down so we have a system that says you
live in this district you go to this
school and the teacher gets this amount
of money no matter what that system it
can't work it couldn't work anywhere
else in business let's just change that
let's average out how much money we
spend right now
on public education particularly let's
do it on a state-by-state basis because
we need to defund the department of
education the federal department of
education you say let me round it
fifteen thousand dollars per student
okay let's say that's what it is instead
of saying we put fifteen thousand
dollars into this municipal school and
you have no choice hey you've got a
fifteen thousand dollar credit that you
can take to any school you want i can't
understand why we wouldn't do that
with the exception of one reason the
unbelievable influence of the teachers
union lobby
what's going on right now cnn's coverage
oh cnn is covering this right now the
teachers let's see what the teachers and
bus driver shortages well you know what
that's the duis let's see what they say
teachers talk about um low pay you've
heard them talk about falling out and
stress not just i love doing the show
live drivers across the country
connecticut starting one thousand bus
drivers down she's currently seeing 200
bus drivers down in st louis they're
giving money to families for gas they're
giving money to older students for metro
cards in places like alaska they're only
serving a third of the students for now
so really scrambling here everyone is
scrambling and coming up with their own
kind of yeah their own ways of trying to
fix it in the short term it's good to
see well it's been in chaos for years
yeah i just add it to the list thank you
well let's talk about this joining me
right now i don't like you other woman
right yes
yeah it's great to see you just go hey
silly glasses let's hear his thank you
so much for being here just before
school started august 8th i believe jack
ruby you said to cnn that you had 1300
vacancies for teachers what does that
number translate to see what it goes the
impact let's see if it uses the things
that we just addressed
low teacher pay
classroom stuff yeah no okay thank you
for having me and thank you for doing
this story this is uh pretty critical
for for our children
with 92 percent of our classrooms filled
with um teachers is that um in our most
underserved communities where we have
our neediest children is where we may
not have a certified licensed educator
um you know as i i continue to say is
really we need to address this crisis
and equities and inequalities here
and in vegas that just means everything
that's off the strip yes
to make sure that we have educators in
the classroom um you know we're
understanding this come up with a
solution what's yours which increase
what are you bitching what's the source
uh teachers selling their prep adding an
extra workload um so it's just really uh
forcing us to find ways
to provide a support system for our our
students uh one of the things that um
you know we need to continue to have a
conversation with our office is really
the the pipeline and how do we continue
to get more more students um you know
out of the higher end institutions to go
into the classroom to go into education
because we what is i have not heard a
single solution yet
just we just had a law signed by
governor ron desantis that what do you
got what do you got jesus
and what he said is we're at the
doorstep of a crisis and i was wondering
in your perspective would you say you're
at the doorstep of a crisis or are you
already there
is your flaming poop um i believe we're
there um you know here in nevada in in
southern nevada we we need 2 000
teachers just to keep up with attrition
and our higher ed institutions here in
nevada i produced 900 this is why i fell
asleep in class all the time um a fully
staffed classroom in since 1994. um wow
yeah and that's the thing that's the
thing i think i want to get to is this
about private schools what about charter
schools
what about those schools in your area
they're doing better are they able to
staff the schools
is it team do you have school choice
is it more what is it is it teacher pay
let's see we just want i think it's it's
a combination i think our teachers did
an amazing job
[Laughter]
but not showing up for two years
when when we went through covet you know
business is closed our educators are
flipped [ __ ] you closed construction
to really provide almost vegas we were
not trained for so in a matter of a
weekend our educators did amazing work
not perfect but did the best they could
and spent they had two years
rhetoric i think is the conversation we
need to have about this profession when
we really look at the working conditions
we are addressing some things that have
a great relationship and partnership
with our teachers union okay so we just
did cover we've already gone through it
covered that's complete bull crap
there's a disparity from what you had to
do what we had to do versus what
teachers said they had it easier than
absolutely anybody let's see if he gets
to teach or pay
and raise it at the end also as well for
um for retention and use some of the
federal dollars to give some retention
bonuses it's very very innovative and
strategic thinking here but we've got
innovative families
here's the thing says retention bonuses
because he can't fire the bad teachers
right let's just give retention bonuses
on top so they need more money so they
can still pay the bad teachers more than
you make on average in the united states
but then we need more money for the good
teachers how about you get rid of the
bad teachers period then you don't need
so many teachers
and now we need to address class size we
need to add classes oh my god we just
went through this this is how
predictable the left's playbook is
please right now if you
share the show if you can sharing is
caring but go check the references at
louderworthcrowder.com we make them
publicly available i will go through
right now the exact claims that we went
through let me just rattle them off we
had teachers aren't allowed to teach
their values in the classroom right
they're being strangled okay we had
teacher pay hasn't come up hasn't gone
up enough we had classroom sizes are too
large and we had that teachers are
afraid because of kova that they weren't
treated fairly this guy just used all of
them every single one
has been rebutted now you may want to
rebut a rebuttal but he's just starting
at the first branch he's not even two
steps in this is how lazy the left is
this is how dumb they think you are
no one's going to sit there and ask them
oh what do you mean though teacher pay
has gone up a lot public education has
gone up by 670 607
something percent six was it 678 percent
yeah that's crazy
somebody in the edit bay right now guys
look up i want to see what is the
average teacher salary in nevada if you
can drill down to clark county i don't
know if that stats available i want to
know what they're doing we have some
history with clark county but by the way
clark county guess guess what that's
where all the casinos are if you're
telling me you can't make enough money
off of taxes on casinos
to fund your schools
i don't want to hear it yeah yeah they
didn't i really don't know
yeah there's blow your brains out at the
table money there right it really is the
one place where nothing i knew some
people who got kovid and quarantined
hand to god at the bellagio
[Laughter]
so they could go play craps at night so
also i was once at uh the orleans and
this is true me and my friend derek and
a guy was eating a chili dog and it fell
off onto the slot machine and he kept
going like this and then still eating it
yeah yeah you don't worry about covet in
vegas no you don't and that was one of
the cleanest things happening in that
casino yeah absolutely
i mean that's the thing with vegas i
mean it's you know supposedly what
happens in vegas that's not true either
no it's not like they need to extradite
you dave by the way you were you were at
the orleans
yeah well
public education i mean still though
yeah let's before we leave get the clark
county or get them to that behind the
paywall if we need to well i would like
i would like for people to see this live
right now because as much as i know that
can seem boring look we just went
through this we spent an hour going
through this piece by piece point by
point and then cnn
does a five whatever 10 minute segment
there's no one there there's no one
sitting there who's going to say hold on
a second teacher pay has gone up there's
no one who's going to say well hold on a
second it's not really class size
because let's be a lot of these private
schools and catholic schools for example
there have been studies that show the
class size it's not the primary driver
no one's going to sit there and say well
hold on a second he said that businesses
shut down but you didn't that's actually
not really true businesses were shut
down for a far shorter amount of time
and by the way
they were not being entirely subsidized
by the federal government doing
everything through zoom for two years no
one's going to say that they're going to
say oh yeah we absolutely need more
money oh because you're the true heroes
they're not going to address the fact
that governor desantis just he said
there's a shortage governor desantis
just created a new pipeline you may not
like it because you don't want veterans
to find work but guess what at least
it's something it's a start and it's
killing two birds with one stone they
will never address the reality these are
such tired talking points yeah that
anyone who uses them at this point
either is completely lazy and uninformed
and assumes you are the same or is lying
to you i don't know that guy so i won't
assume he's lying but i know that he's
wrong do we have the teacher pay yeah
this is from glassdoor this is eleven
hundred salaries jeez
sixty eight thousand sixty eight
thousand sixty nine seven clark county
yeah claire county
that's the median salary
based on 1100 salaries that people input
so that's not even the average that's
the median
from what i'm seeing i can't say the
chart there but that way it ranges from
50 000 to 101 000. oh
so the lowest meaning when you start
teaching 50 000 that's your start pay
that's your start pay in clark county
come on
start there's a lot of good places to
squat there too yes oh my gosh well if
you just get a place at circus circus
you can live for free yes exactly just
make sure you know you're ready for the
metal detectors but they're easy to beat
start start is 45 000 that's in the
possible range but okay i just saw that
that uh jesus yara guy that we just saw
he just
um
he just made some changes that changed
it from 45 to 50. my mother called me
this is going to be different
50 000 to start you know what you have
to have you have to have a four-year
degree you can get that online right now
right so this is not like you have to be
a rocket scientist i hate to use that
again but this is not what we're saying
you have to have a four-year degree you
can get it online without even taking
classes that's true i'm an ordained
minister then me too i've done three
things i'd have to pass a subject
specific exam
that's all we're talking about and you
get 50 000
a year to do that it's the
self-important bull look
does anyone here believe that the most
qualified people to teach are people who
studied teaching
in college is that what you actually
believe or do you know people have you
known people throughout your lives who
are good teachers i had a tutor i never
cracked open a math book my senior year
it was a senior year exam in quebec
around montreal where we grew up the the
south uh southport
south shore school board
and uh our district and everyone failed
it was something like 70 something
percent failed this government exam
and i passed i was like the top five in
my class and i only had like a 75 i
didn't do that well i never opened a
math textbook because i had an awful
teacher nice guy a guy named mr lovell
was a nice man a very very nice man i
liked his company very much but i had
him my senior year i had him my junior
year my brother had him his senior year
my brother had him his junior year and
guess what
so did johnny boy he had him before my
brother this guy taught all of the math
classes for your last two years of high
school and no one passed he was the
worst teacher that i've ever seen in my
life everyone failed and when it came
time to the government exam at the end
of the year a good year a good year
would be 60-something percent of his
graduating class actually passed the
standardized test so my senior year
after having him for an entire year i
said you know what i'm going to open my
math textbook because i'm not going to
learn anything he sits around he would
literally sit around doing a dance he
would give you a homework he'd come in
he'd correct the homework and he was
usually wrong and so i said i'm going to
go to a tutor this guy named mr peters
he was a uh
from trinidad and tobago should talk
about cricket most boring sport i can
possibly imagine but i really he wasn't
a teacher
i did eight sessions with him eight
one-hour sessions and i passed my math
example an entire year really two years
with mr lovell nice man i want to be
clear i don't want people to think that
he was just not a good teacher nice man
two years eight one hour sessions and i
guarantee you that's not atypical i
guarantee you plenty of you right now
spent time with a tutor and you actually
learn something
you don't need a degree in teaching you
just need to be passionate about
actually imparting wisdom
into children guess what a lot of these
teachers aren't a lot of these teachers
are not we want to assume that they are
but they are not they see your children
as an opportunity to indoctrinate
many of them not all of them are
miserable pricks
and they have no business being around
your kids
personally and professionally they suck
at their job so let's just do this fund
the student not the schools we've been
doing this the same way for a very long
time it hasn't worked nothing's improved
they're saying more money please more
money please more money please i've just
given you four different potential
solutions all of which have been
proposed by either a governor or some
type of a senator so these are not
things that are completely off the
reservations these are proposals that
have been made for a very long time
let's try it differently how about that
just try it differently instead of being
a fool or a synonym for that is a public
school teacher we're going to go to mug
club here and talk about uh the games
diss track of eminem oh that's going to
be fun can't talk about that here piss
off youtube
do
[Music]